I don't know ciserek three maybe George
Jefferson and the Merchant of Venice
please invest without pound of flesh duh
mister Yama Code makes the whole outfit
in Elizabeth Alexandra Byrnes costume
designs were inspired by historical
research and the tumultuous lives of
those in the court of Elizabeth the
Virgin Queen now she's the brilliant and
quirky star six days and seven nights
which is how long the show is going to
run if I say what I really want to say
about this beard on my face ladies and
gentlemen a wonderful young actress Miss
Anne Heche
you want to hear the truth this is phase
two of the 71st Academy Awards phase 1
took place last month at a movies slang
war what Denny 36 count 36 hello
do you want to know the truth because
I'm gonna tell it this is phase two of
the 71st Academy Awards phase one took
place last month at a jam-packed
celebration of the movies scientific and
technical awards
I had the pleasant challenge of
presenting a 36 count them 36 plaques
and one Oscar to the inventors engineers
and technicians who make the making of
movies easier and safer here are the two
gentlemen who accepted the Oscar for the
concept system design and engineering of
the avid film composer from motion
picture editing bill Miller chairman and
CEO and Bill Warner founder of avid
very much this award belongs to all the
2,000 talented people around the world
that are avid technology and a whole
crew of editors and artists that avid
made the critical bridge between the
technologically possible and the
creatively useful so to all of you thank
you let me also give you the assurance
you ain't seen nothing yet thank you
very much there were many more speeches
that night and it was great fun to hear
from people who can honestly say that
they know what they are doing in this
business for movie fans everywhere I
thank them for the two hundred and eight
thousand five hundred films that were
released so far in this century now go
see all of them thank you